[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw this story i wanted to bring in
jeff passing
the new york mets general manager jared
porter acknowledges sending explicit
images to a female reporter when he
worked for the chicago cubs
i believe this is back in 2016. he was
hired
by the mets to be their general manager
he is no longer the mets general manager
because he has been fired
and jeff passin from the mother ship who
covers baseball joining us on the
program when did you get
first word about this uh something that
was done in
back in 2016 with the cubs
me personally dan was very recently okay
but
uh my colleague mina kimes uh
first was given the text back in 2017
december of 2017 and
uh went and met with the woman and
talked with her about possibly
doing a story on this at the time she
was not ready for that she was still
working in the journalism industry and
she was afraid that the blowback from a
story being published was going to
significantly harm her career
she is no longer in journalism and as
she saw
jared porter's ascent to general manager
of the mets
you know it hit her there's a person who
did something to me
and his career is on an upward
trajectory
i'm the victim in this situation and i
now don't have my dream job anymore
why is this fair why is this okay why is
uh from all i can gather dan
the mets found out when we told them
that we were going to be publishing this
story yesterday
that they did not know about this
beforehand that it caught them
off guard you know inside of baseball
let's go back to 2016 with the cubs
there was one other person in the cubs
organization at the time
who found out about it afterward because
the woman had
gone to her employer and someone at her
employer had called up
somebody with the cubs uh who that
person knew
and that person with whom we spoke
yesterday
said that he was trying to essentially
be a go-between to bring the woman
and porter together to have some kind of
a resolution for this that never
happened she was considering
legal action at the time she says that
he was pushing her not to pursue legal
action
um how many texts messages did he send
this woman
in total it was a hundred fifty or so
the the majority of those were at the
beginning they had met at yankee stadium
and she thought hey you know we're going
to talk baseball he's going to be a
source that's what reporters do
trying to cultivate sources but very
quickly
uh the the messages from porter went
beyond the normal
source relationship to a point where he
was asking her out
trying to get her to come and visit him
in different places across the country
and after he sent one particular picture
uh which he says wasn't him but was uh
of a man
laying on a bed with a bulge in his
pants uh she stopped responding
after she stopped responding there were
more than 60 texts
from jared porter that culminated
uh with a picture of a naked penis
and that is where we are and that is
ultimately i think
uh what got him fired not just the the
lewd image itself
but the fact that it came after she had
not responded to
60 plus texts what's uh the reaction
from uh
the new owner steve cohen i mean you saw
it this
morning he got fired before 8 a.m
eastern and this was a story that was
published about 11 o'clock last night so
it didn't even
take half a day and steve cohen if you
remember in his initial press conference
said we want this to be an organization
of integrity and he referenced that
again
this morning in the tweet uh in which he
announced the firing publicly he said i
want to run this organization with
integrity and
uh we could not do that with him in
charge
and this had been a pretty good
off-season with the trade getting lindor
from cleveland uh they helped their
pitching staff here
um and i go back to last year with
carlos beltran does beltron get another
chance here jeff well aj hinch has
gotten another chance no
i know that's why alex scores alex cora
has gotten another chance
it stands to reason that carlos beltran
would get another chance considering the
other two who have
yeah just trying to figure that out
because that was with the mets as well
um are they a cursed organization
do we look at them sort of the the way
we do the knicks
dan i'm from cleveland so if anyone's
going to believe in curry if anyone's
going to believe in curses
it's me and i still do not believe in
the idea of a cursed organization what i
do believe in is the idea of culture
and that culture can perpetuate itself
through a place and metastasize
and that getting rid of that cancer
inside of an organization can take a
really
long time but but it's possible like
let's not look past the idea that the
new york mets
can one day become a functional
organization
if things are done correctly and in
something like this you know
when you make a mistake you can either
double down on it
or you can acknowledge quickly that it
was a mistake
and i i think the mets did so in this
case and that's a good
first step in writing the error of your
ways
good to visit with you you and mina did
a great job a deep dive on this at
espn.com thank you jeff
my pleasure to have you jeff panson espn
baseball insider